first of all I wanna talk to you guys
about the download speed thing just a
little bit yeah because you download it
on PC like you said it and signed a new
order you downloaded and say five
minutes gigs right 34-36 case 37 on exit
bone so obviously on the our pipe here
super fast so we get it as quickly as
they can give it steam is always super
fast that's like a given yeah and when
it comes to the console is I always find
PlayStation 4 is about twice as fast as
xbox live at this game Xbox yeah there's
because there's I mean their whole
status bar thing is like I don't know
it's just it doesn't give you a good
idea of how long it's going to take it
goes irregularly and it feels like it's
going slow I do think that my connection
as a caveat is going through a router of
some kind of not just right into the
rail that we have but yeah I I would say
you know in terms of getting frequently
download stuff on PC vs ps4 vs xbox one
kind of goes in that order in the arms
of speed and what why yeah it's kind of
annoying I always wondered if it was the
if it was the xbox live gold versus like
having a PlayStation Plus subscription
go like a both of them yeah I don't know
like but with it with the PlayStation
stuff I always feel like whenever i buy
game FBI said there's a chance I can
play it that night whereas I'm almost
like reside to the fact that if i buy a
game or if i get a game on disk and i
put it in and it's got 20 gigs of
uploads I'm like oh well I guess that's
tomorrow yeah yeah the next box does
that like ready to start thing but it
does oh yeah but it's never which is
like oh sweet battlefields ready to
start you booted up and it's like cool
we play the first level of single-player
have you feel about tutorials we got
your back multiplayer yes still working
on is that do you think that's is that a
problem for you guys like it's getting a
little bit irritating for me that like
my ps4 sign Phillip that's starting to
irritate me a little bit and then like
buying like being forced even getting
retail copies of games and then being
forced to waste another three hours to
actually play them like is that a big
walk selling point for you or a problem
I'm just so used to steam though right
cuz like even though my pretty fast
internet pipe and so I can just pull
games down I've seemed kind of if
there's a big one I might have to wait
like an hour yeah like ooh but if i buy
a game on xbox one I know that I'm like
well I better set this to download go to
work hopefully it's done by then I get
back it probably won't be because it
like failures yeah I am yeah super
unreliable and and I'm all four digit
like getting everything digital a
digital yeah cuz that's just how it's
been on pc for so long i love it it but
it's not it's not there yet on xbox so
it's like I almost rather have the disk
I don't want to play if like I'm gonna
go swing by you know a store and buy the
disc so I can play it when I get home
hmm I still do that if I really think
i'm going to do that honestly at this
point if the the install time stuff I've
sort of adjusted my expectations so this
morning I was impatient but I'd I was
under no delusions that a 36 gig
download my phone was going to go in 45
minutes mmm i get home i said well like
set up whatever game i want to download
and play and then bye you know get home
around seven by about ten when my wife
goes to bed and I've like time to play
it's about ready the thing that gets me
is the system updates that are
substantial yet and take downloading
because I don't leave my systems on all
day in like draining Ghost power mode I
don't know it's like it's negligible I
know but it's just the thing I don't do
it so like getting getting jabbed with
one of those updates derails my schedule
and that's even when you're like sitting
down to like watch something on Netflix
it's like you need an update if you want
to get up to the internet like oh and I
tried I just switch back to the other
system that doesn't need an updated yeah
it's the horrible part of the day all
digital future nobody follows its
revelation oh I was at his about seems
like unlimited bandwidth yeah do you
know theoretically I pulled down fifty
six gigs of GTA 5 when it was coming out
at like 50 megabytes a second really on
this connection yeah but then I like
downloaded on a different computer the
one was like try us ally yeah and it was
capped out at like 18 megabytes and then
I couldn't get it to go back up oh
really so I think steam does my they
throttle its own I throttle it because
that was a very high demand game a very
like release day yeah so they may
throttle it but that's still pretty good
at making my second yeah I'm not gonna
stick my nose open 18 mega second and
thank so much guys
you